suite de notre coup d'oeil sur la
campagne des têtes de listes régionales
xavier naizet et sandrine lopez ensuivie
jacqueline gourault sur le terrain face
à la liste amie mais néanmoins
concurrente de l'ump la chef de file de
l'udf entend se démarquer sur le fond
mais aussi sur la forme
c'était une comment dire une tradition
famille et or du tout travaillé le
meuble
quand on est candidat aux régionales il
faut savoir s'intéresser à tous une
laiterie le matin une ébénisterie du
perche
l'après midi est discutée entendre
comprendre c'est le style que jacqueline
gourault veut donner à sa campagne
elle n'arrive pas avec des solutions
elle se veut à l'écouté
j'ai discuté beaucoup sur le perche sur
ce qui se passait dans le perche pour
voir un peu quelles sont leurs remarques
etc
j'ai déjeuné aussi avec des éleveurs
laitiers donc vous sentir je dirais le
territoire s'est pas uniquement pour
venir faire des promesses pour
s'imprégner complètement du territoire
et puis pour montrer aussi aux gens
qu'on s'intéresse à eux qu'on est près
d'eux en venant sur le territoire quand
on vient sur un territoire c'est pas
forcément pour promène d'ailleurs les
gens ne nous dise pas qu'est ce que vous
venez nous nous promettent ils nous
disent on est content que vous veniez
nous voir chez nous
l'udf un besoin vital de se distinguer
de l'ump et ça passe avant tout par la
communication et l'image
écoutez merci beaucoup ça fait plaisir
de voir des artisans heureux qu'ils
trouvent des apprentis qui sont heureux
qui voit là des passionnés par ce
conduit à transmettre son savoir et on a
besoin voilà c'est bien c'est l'été jour
versé votre accueil
sur le fond les programmes ump udf sont
assez proches
hormis quelques petites différences
comme les questions de santé jacqueline
gourault veut en faire une priorité
régionale
quelques heures après s'être intéressé à
la filière bois du perche elle était à
tour pour rencontrer des médecins
je pense que si la région pouvait équipe
et je dirais le sanitaire de quelques
hélicoptères à l'intérieur de la région
pour rapprocher les gens qui sont très
éloignées des centres hospitaliers au
moins je dirais on apporte une réponse
immédiate en fait un tour en compte très
peu de médecins dans l'assistance la
plupart des participants sont soit des
candidats de l'udf aux régionales soit
des sympathisants déjà encartés le
lendemain après un détour par sa mairie
de la chaussée saint victor à jacqueline
gourault et à orléans pour accueillir
corinne lepage
l'ancienne ministre de l'environnement
de jacques chirac candidate en ile de
france sur la liste santini fait le tour
des régions en région centre c'est
programme minimum une petite balade en
bord de loire
organisée pour la presse la soie lacé
vraiment les paysages les rien avec ce
temps de brouillard campagne c'est beau
hein
comme la veille et jacqueline gourault
termine sa journée par une réunion
publique à fleury-les-aubrais en
banlieue d'orléans
comme la veille l'assistance est
essentiellement composée d'élus et de
sympathisants de l'udf
comme la veille on sent que malgré le
choc du 21 avril 2002 il faudra du temps
pour renouer le fil entre les français
et la politique